accusations of harmful content have long
dogged social media giants and as the
british government works out how to
protect people online the whistleblower
taking on facebook brought her searing
assessment to a commons committee
facebook is unwilling to acknowledge its
own power
it believes in a world of flatness which
hides the difference like children are
not adults
right uh they they believe in flatness
and they won't accept the consequences
of their actions and so i think that is
negligence and it is um
in
ignorance francis haugen worked at
facebook for two years before leaking
tens of thousands of pages of internal
documents today she said the company
can't be trusted and pushes people
towards extreme content if you get an
eating disorder when you're 16 you may
have osteoporosis for the rest of your
life right they're going to be women who
are walking around this earth in 60
years with brittle bones because of
choices facebook made now
when she
didn't get top marks she used to be
quite grumpy
which is quite normal for an athlete i
think it is especially difficult
evidence for keith to hear he'll never
know exactly what led his daughter to
take her own life so he had long
struggled with eating disorders it was
only after she died that her parents
found what she'd been viewing online
she became anorexic she was spurred on
by social media i believe
and as the more as she became more
prolifically involved in anorexia she
was looking at some pretty awful content
online
where girls were sharing information
about self-harm we never knew
we never knew until she died
if we'd have known what was going on and
what she was looking at at the time we
would have taken a phone away from her
the reason that the facebook
whistleblower francis hogan was here was
to give evidence to a committee that is
scrutinizing the long-awaited online
harms bill the current proposals include
giving ofcom powers to regulate social
media sites and make them able to force
companies to have a duty of care to
protect users from legal but harmful
content companies in breach of the rules
could face fines of up to 18 million
pounds or 10 of their annual turnover
the government said it would also have
the power to block access to these sites
in the uk
facebook say they're changing they make
new accounts private or friends only by
default for people under 18 and direct
anyone searching about topics like
eating disorders to organizations that
can help we've invested more than 13
billion dollars since 2016 and we have
more than 40 000 people
working on safety and security at this
company now the details of the bill are
not yet settled and we're going to stay
closely engaged on that and continue to
talk to regulators about it but overall
we think regulation is a very good and
much needed thing
do you think facebook listening
but facebook know that they are under
intense scrutiny and the powerful threat
that comes with a credible whistleblower
ali fortescue sky news